Anthony's in New York
hi Anthony welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey did they stick in the call sure
what's up so my journey somebody wore my
left out pregnant in February I kinda
got overwhelmed with all my dad and I
started tackling and tackling and I paid
off a lot of it sometime
we just had her baby and our parents are
finally more at home but we're looking
to buy a house so my question is sure
we're buying the house from them so we
are mama babysit - should we buy the
house from them that was a great deal at
this point should we so have them keep
the house currently in their name and
does work on tackling our debt and we
don't have much left I think I have
about $23,000 left which I plan to pay
off by next summer because it really the
only question is now the question is do
we buy the house in our next summer yeah
next summer and I would even if it like
it's gonna be the same deal next summer
yeah it would be no more pain to live
there anyways right now it's no big deal
the waiting costs you nothing no except
just your being impatient you want to
buy a house you got a new baby and your
wife said biosphere daddy said you want
to show you how she won't buy a house
but don't buy a house when you're broke
you're still broke I understand
my wife's child the home we've been
living there for like seven eight years
but they're finally going to put it in
our name and they're gonna hold the
mortgage so um that's why I was
wondering if we should come around but I
don't have much left and I do plan to
pay it off very fast yeah summer do the
deal and I'm gonna give you another
piece of advice that nobody in your
family's gonna like me when we're done I
would not let them carry in the mortgage
I just go get me a mortgage so they're
doing the person I know is gonna get
signed over so it's all to the lawyers
are back in the carrier it's gonna be in
our name but we're just making an
agreement with them to buy it because
we're both self-employed so our incomes
not the highest
you're gonna pay them a mortgage payment
crack I would not do that you're going
to change the way Thanksgiving dinner
tastes
I sell well the borrower is slave to the
lender and when you borrow money from
someone it changes your relationship
with them and no matter how sweet they
are or how strong and dignified you are
that is not an option it changes
everything you're gonna do it anyway but
you're gonna regret doing it and you're
gonna remember the day that dave ramsey
told you not to do it it's gonna come
back and bite you in the butt please
don't do this
hey thanks for the call the old joke is
if you loan your brother-in-law $100 and
he never speaks to you again was it
worth it when you do debt transactions
with someone you are enacting a
universal truth that is independent of
your wishes your thoughts or your
desires
you are a slave even if you have a nice
master even if your master is loving and
kind you still have a master even if
your master is your father-in-law you
still have a master the borrower is
slave to the lender don't screw up
relationships borrowing money or loaning
money to people you're gonna get
yourself in a pinch folk don't do it
thirty years of me watching what causes
cancer that causes cancer